Wusstet ihr, dass man in Deutschland Erdnüsse
anbauen kann?
Das behauptet zumindest das Internet.
Ich möchte dieses Jahr ausprobieren, ob das
wirklich funktioniert.
Ich habe meine ersten Erdnüsse gesät.
Die werden dann in meinen Garten gepflanzt,
und dann werde ich euch berichten, wie das
Ganze funktioniert.
Erdnüsse sind übrigens super faszinierende
Pflanzen.
Die Nüsse wachsen nämlich gar nicht von
Anfang an unten in der Erde, sondern die Pflanze
bildet ganz normal überirdisch Blüten aus,
dann bilden sich daran die kleinen Nüsse,
wenn die Blüten verblüht sind, und je größer
die Nüsse in diesen Hülsen werden, desto
mehr senken sie sich dem Erdboden entgegen.
Dann bohrt die Pflanze die Erdnüsse in den
Boden, und so gelangen sie erst dahin.
Das ist sozusagen so, als würde sie ihre
eigenen Kinder selber pflanzen.
Total cool und faszinierend.
Ich bin super gespannt, wie das dann in echt
aussehen wird in unserem Garten, und ob wir
das da wirklich beobachten werden.
Ich bin da auf jeden Fall jetzt schon Feuer
und Flamme für dieses Experiment.
Sagt mal, ob ihr schon mal Erdnüsse angebaut
habt, oder ob ihr Lust habt, dieses Experiment
dieses Jahr mit mir zu machen, und auch ein
paar Erdnüsse in euren Garten pflanzen werdet.
Schreibt mir gerne mal in die Kommentare,
was ihr davon haltet.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall sehr gespannt.
Ich habe mir Saatgut von zwei verschiedenen
Herstellern bestellt.
Bei dem einen waren leider nur noch Krümel
drin.
Da ist irgendwas beim Transport schiefgegangen.
Also probieren wir jetzt mal die aus.
Die Samen lasse ich jetzt 24 Stunden einweichen,
bevor ich sie in die Erde säe.
Schauen wir mal, wie viele hier drin sind.
Auch eine Kaputte, oder zwei.
So, und die Samen hier, die lasse ich jetzt
über Nacht einweichen in einem Glas mit Wasser,
damit die schon mal vorkeimen können.
Das ist oft ein ganz guter Trick, damit mehr
Samen anwachsen.
Ich gärtnere übrigens nach den Aussaattagen
von Maria Thun.
Das ist der Demeter Aussaatkalender.
Ich habe das schon ziemlich ruiniert hier,
das Heft beim Aussäen.
Das sind alle Tage aufgeteilt in Frucht-,
Wurzel-, Blüte- oder Blatttage.
Fruchtgemüse wäre sowas wie Tomate, Wurzelgemüse
natürlich Möhren und sowas, und da versuche
ich immer, an diesen Fruchttagen das Fruchtgemüse
zu säen, an den Wurzeltagen das Wurzelgemüse.
Die Maria Thun hat da ganz viele Experimente
gemacht mit den Aussaattagen, und festgestellt,
dass es wirklich einen großen Unterschied
macht, ob man das Gemüse an dem richtigen
Tag sät, oder nicht.
Ob man jetzt daran glaubt, oder nicht, ist
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen Typsache.
Ich glaube fest dran und habe damit sehr gute
Erfahrungen gemacht.
Den Link zu den Aussaattagen, also diesem
Aussaatkalender kann ich euch gerne nochmal
hier unter dem Video in die Videobeschreibung
packen.
So, die Samen sind gut vorgequollen.
Ich packe jetzt jeweils zwei Samenkörner
in jedes dieser Töpfchen.
Ich möchte am Ende gerne vier Pflanzen haben,
und so kann ich sichergehen, dass dann auch
in jedem Töpfchen ein Same aufgeht, und wir
am Ende vier kräftige Pflanzen haben.
Falls in einem Töpfchen zwei Pflanzen aufgehen,
entscheide ich mich einfach für die kräftigere
Pflanze und reiß die andere raus.
Auch wenn es fies ist, aber so haben wir dann
am Ende vier kräftige Pflanzen, die wir in
den Garten pflanzen können.
Erdnüsse brauchen eine Keimtemperatur von
mindestens 25 Grad.
Die mögen es sehr warm zum Keimen.
Deswegen stelle ich meine auf die Heizung.
Das ist allerdings keine Heizung, die den
ganzen Tag volle Pulle aufgedreht ist.
Ich drehe die meistens maximal auf drei, eher
noch ein bisschen drunter, so dass die Erdnüsse
es schon schön warm haben, aber nicht gebraten
werden.
Unsere Erdnusspflänzchen sind mittlerweile
aufgegangen.
Ich habe die jetzt auch in so größere Töpfchen
hier umgepflanzt, weil sie doch sehr schnell
sehr wenig Platz hatten in den kleinen Töpfchen.
Ich bin ganz erstaunt, wie schnell die wachsen.
Die sehen auch wunderschön aus, und natürlich
habe ich es nicht übers Herz gebracht, die
einzelnen schwächeren Erdnusspflänzchen
auszureißen.
Deswegen haben wir jetzt doch ein paar mehr
Pflänzchen.
Geht es euch auch immer so?
Ich bin immer so voller Zärtlichkeit für
so kleine Pflanzen.
Ich kann die dann einfach nicht rausreißen.
Es ist mitten in der Nacht.
Ich bin gerade nochmal aufgewacht und ins
Bad gegangen, wo meine Jungpflänzchen gerade
stehen, und da habe ich was ganz Süßes beobachtet.
Die Erdnüsse, die klappen nämlich wenn es
dunkel ist die Blätter zusammen, als ob sie
die Augen zumachen würden.
Irgendwie schon ganz schön niedlich, oder?
Von meinem Gefühl her würde ich die Erdnüsse
erst Mitte Mai rauspflanzen, wenn keine Fröste
mehr drohen.
Es kann sein, dass es denen dann in den Töpfchen
auch schon wieder zu eng wird und ich sie
nochmal umtopfen muss.
Wir werden sehen.
Wenn ihr andere Erfahrungen gemacht habt,
und die schon früher ausgepflanzt habt, dann
lasst mich das gerne mal unten in den Kommentaren
wissen.
Ich werde euch auf jeden Fall berichten, wie
es mit den Erdnüssen weitergeht.
Hier drüben findet ihr noch ein anderes spannendes
Video, und da unten auch.
Ich freue mich, wenn wir uns da gleich wiedersehen.
Bis dann.
Tschüss.